Tom Brady of course the uncertainty
about his future this week very relaxed
I just don't know what's gonna happen
and you know I'm not gonna predict it I
was a iconic figure in this organization
nobody respects Tom more than I do
I think Brady has reached his lifetime
limit of dealing with a jerk like Bill
Belichick he wants to get his butt
kissed both cheeks baby
future unclear for job-ready love
playing for this tune for two decades
and and winning a lot of game I just I
don't know what it looks like moving
forward the future of Tom Brady still to
be determined a hot topic in
Indianapolis counting combine is all the
reporters are there trying to one-up
each other with some little new nugget
and then they they argue about who had
what first or is this really news and
the local writers get resentful when the
National people have something or when
the National people try to report
something the local writers have
previously said it's a fun terrarium of
humanity as the reporters fight with
each other over this Tom Brady's story
but it's the biggest story right now in
the NFL it will be until we know where
he's going to sign big cats so what
we're going to do in light of the news
that Tom Brady's agent Donny has met
with or will be meeting with the
Chargers the Raiders and the cults while
in Indianapolis tampering central
everybody does it for every free agent
even the guys who did franchise tag they
talked about them just to see what the
value is and just to brace for what may
be coming let's do some Tom Brady
landing spots superlatives and we've got
several different categories we're gonna
begin with the easiest one the most
logical place for Tom Brady to sign big
cat what's your what's your thought can
I pick the Patriots cuz that would be
the most logical place for Tom Brady
juice ATS my that's my pick yeah I know
I know the report came out you know
yesterday that people need to start
bracing themselves at the end of the day
I've been saying this for the last
couple months I think that Tom Brady
Bob Kraft Bill Belichick we'll all get
together for a dinner have a good cry
cry it out airing of grievance and then
signed for two more years because that
guy right there the picture you're
watching it's about it's about Bob Kraft
more than anything because he wants Tom
Brady to be a patriot he wants Tom Brady
to never play for another team I think
he will kind of flex his muscles here
and make sure that everyone comes to the
table and Tom Brady stays a patriot and
now apparently the athletic says that
the report that the Colts will be
talking to Brady is incorrect so this is
just an example of this circular firing
squad among media that is going to play
out in Indianapolis and beyond and I
agree with you the
makes the most sense now here's the
thing the Patriots organization has been
set up for Bill Belichick to make the
football decisions there was a report
Super Bowl Sunday that the Patriots are
willing to pay Tom Brady more than 30
million a year well that's the size of
the check Robert Kraft is willing to
sign whether or not Bill Belichick who
controls the purse strings will allow it
is a different issue and someone told me
yesterday that we have to be accounting
for the possibility that Robert Kraft
Trump's Bill Belichick on this one he's
never done it right wait what if he's
ever gonna do it whoa whoa what do you
mean he's never done it you think Bill
Belichick wanted to trade Jimmy
Garoppolo yes okay yes I do okay if you
think you want to trim okay okay well I
think I don't know what's true and
what's not true there because there have
been all sorts of reports and Counting
reports I just think here the way they
set this up is that Robert Kraft is
basically Pontius Pilate in this that
it's not his call it's not up to me it's
Bill Belichick and I think if Bill
Belichick begins to make that call right
that's when Robert Kraft may decide to
get involved and say look we have to
keep Tom Brady because you know this is
weird vibe in New England and I was on
with fell grandmas on 98.5 the Sports
Hub right before the Super Bowl
and and they're convinced that if Tom
Brady leaves Bob crafts gonna be blamed
for it it's like this is ridiculous to
me why would you blame him you got
twenty years with a six round pick one
ninety nine overall six Super Bowl wins
he's reached a point where he's become a
free agent if he wants to leave he wants
to leave how is it Robert crafts fault
but the thing is you can't change
people's minds you know the mob doesn't
respond well to logic and it could be
that Robert Kraft ultimately decides
look we're gonna do whatever we have to
do to keep this guy and we're gonna
offer him so much that if he does leave
it's not our fault and it is the most
logical place for Tom Brady to be but if
he senses Bill Belichick doesn't really
want him it may not matter how much
Robert Kraft offers him so to that point
I actually think it serves Robert Kraft
better to stay completely out of it and
never enter into this and never try to
push Bill Belichick one way or the other
and and basically say Bill Belichick to
coach the team he's got
he makes all the decisions that's how he
stays out of the blame in my mind it's
when he gets involved and it doesn't
happen that's when he could potentially
get some blame but the argument will be
you should get involved to keep Tom
Brady here right why do you like Bill
Belichick make this decision this is a
very specific in particular situation
where Bill Belichick because of his
resume because of those Pelt's on the
wall
Bob Kraft can say I'm staying completely
out of it and I think everyone would
understand that's the right thing to do
best team to stick it to the Patriots
obviously the Patriots can't be an
answer here yeah Tom Brady for forty
million dollars you said that they
weren't gonna interview them but the
best team to stick it to the Patriots
would be the Indianapolis Colts right
because of deflate gate because of
Peyton Manning versus Brady all of that
the colts would be the most logical
place to stick it to them I'm obviously
not throwing out there the New York
Giants because they had Daniel Jones but
the Colts are in the market and there is
history there between them and the
Patriots I agree with you on the Colts I
guess to add some variety of the
conversation I'd say the Jets that would
stick it to the Patriots because that
long history of acrimony the Bill
Parcells the Bill Belichick the the the
remember the stupid tampering charges
that were made by the Jets against the
Patriots after Darrelle Revis left and
Bob Kraft made a comment about Darrelle
Revis and the Jets filed tampering
charge has been a long long history of
hatred between the two organizations so
if you really want to stick it to the
Patriots join a team that plays the
Patriots twice per year and that is the
New York Jets all right the team that
would cause the most chaos if Tom Brady
joined in would be the chaos factor I
would say the chaos would be I think the
Titans actually would be the chaos
because they are good enough to really
to to upset the applecart where I just
don't I don't believe in the Chargers
enough right I don't believe in the
Raiders enough what I'm talking about
the totality of the team
chaos to me is a team that could be in
the Super Bowl with Tom Brady in a
different uniform that's chaos that's
gonna be weird if the Patriots and the
Titans play again next year in the
playoffs Tom Brady playing against them
would be chaos so I'm gonna go with the
Titans you didn't see that coming
well I didn't see it coming because for
me chaos I view it through the prism of
being the owner and operator or a media
outlet that thrives on chaos for cliques
and for attention and for traffic and
for me see the chaos comes from the
attention generated by the arrival of
Brady plus the cleaning up of the loose
ends based upon who they already have
and what happens with Ryan Tannehill
isn't all that sexy I think very 2012
with with Peyton Manning when Peyton
Manning joins the Broncos boom when the
Broncos dumped Tim Tebow in their next
move mega boom so the Cowboys that's the
ultimate chaos because you get Tom Brady
in Dallas and then you got to do
something with that Prescott and it's
the Cowboys for crying out loud
it's Jerry Jones making that ultimate
all-in move and big Cal you know we were
talking earlier in the week like where's
the best place for him to have a chance
to win right away and position himself
to get to the Super Bowl well you know
the charges and Raiders want him but do
you really want to compete with Patrick
mahomes you want to go to a place where
you to win the division and you're gonna
be the 1 seed especially now that the 1
seed is the only team that gets the by
the NFC East was the worst division in
football this year go to the Cowboys win
the division get the 1 seed I like the
pick but also it would be the most chaos
the Titans the AFC South is the easiest
division to win every single year what
are you talking about Mike you've
watched like the antsy South is better
in the NFC East now I don't know about
that the Eagles and the Eagles what a
healthy Eagles team would would would
pose a bigger threat to the Cowboys than
any other team the answer heats up Mike
I just want everyone to take this moment
understand what just happened here Mike
Florio cares more about what happens off
the field then on the field big cat Dan
cats I care about the product on the
field I'm a football fan Mike is a fan
of covering football big difference
okay so so I am a fan of covering
football it has it has rewarded me well
over the last 20 years I'm not going to
deny it when little kids grow up and
they have Patrick mahomes posters on
their walls Mike Florio little Mike
Florio has Bob Costas and Michael's he
had those posters and chris burrman on
his wall so just want that on the record
all right I'm not gonna argue with you
about it I mean you think that things
like you try to find things it'll bother
me that doesn't bother me I'll wear that
I'll wear that that that as a badge of
honor all right
a person with the best chance to sell
Brady on a landing spot is hmm I mean
I'm gonna double dip here but it's my
kraebel right it's Mike yeah they're
history's he had in the Titans and I
think that that would be the most
compelling personal case that can be
made I'll throw in a dark horse though
how about Brian Flores and the Miami
Dolphins and then you also add Steven
Ross Michigan man Michigan men's stick
together so there's my dark horse for
the person or people that would most
likely be able to convince him to leave
I'll go ahead and take Flores then cuz I
agree with you on Frey but when we met
with for Abel the other day he had the
demeanor of a guy who's sitting on
something right there like Tannehill
they're like strangely ambivalent about
the guy who had the 4th highest
single-season passer rating in NFL
history like something's going on there
with the Titans but you know with with
the Dolphins like the media and the fans
have had removed the Dolphins from the
list simply because both Steven Ross and
Brian Flores have said I don't know why
you'd want to come here well that
doesn't mean they're not interested
right I don't know why you'd want to
come here what if he does that answers
the question if he wants you do you want
him and of course you want him if he
wants you you got Ryan Fitzpatrick I
love Ryan Fitzpatrick but he's not Tom
Brady if Tom Brady calls Stephen Ross or
Brennan Flores and says hey why aren't
you guys showing interest in me I'd like
to play there that changes everything so
yeah I think and and we can't overlook
the importance and I don't want to make
this all about what Gisele Bundchen
wants to do
a factor in this it's a family decision
she's dealt with this guy playing into
his 40s and if she wants to live in
Miami which isn't all that far from
Costa Rica and it's a lot closer to her
native country of Brazil than any other
place in the u.s. you can't write off
the dolphins from the standpoint of him
being interested in them they are
playing that game of why would he be
interested in us well maybe he will be
all right one more
best place for Tom Brady to win a Super
Bowl in 2020 go San Francisco 49ers they
let Jimmy G go and then he goes to San
Francisco he goes home so to speak to
the Bay Area and there it is by the way
what was the Costa Rica thing there
that's just where they like to vacation
have a house they got a lot of many
houses there I love this stuff yeah so I
just actually saw Tom Brady's kids there
looking at private school in Costa Rica
first reported here all right hey here's
mine and I put this category in just to
be a smart aleck I was on Sirius XM mad
dog radio with Nick Wright the other
night and he made this Brad I'm gonna
steal it the best yeah they have really
the best place for him to win a Super
Bowl in 2020 is the Kansas City Chiefs
as Patrick mahomes back up boom boom
Vegas has spoken regarding the odds for
the next destination of Tom Brady
including his current destination New
England the favorite at minus 175 for
the folks out there who don't bet that
means you get about 175 to win a hundred
everybody else in plus territory
Tennessee mmm Mike Vrabel hmm plus 380
Las Vegas Raiders plus 500 the Chargers
plus 600 the Giants plus a thousand
Tampa Bay plus 1,100 I think those odds
should be a little bit lower than that
big cat and then the Cowboys in the
Dolphins Plus 2,900 maybe the Dolphins
at plus 2900 the good bet
the shocking one there's the Giants at a
thousand what is that just because Joe
judge that one seems very bizarre that
report came out of the blue yesterday I
think it was mighty arty of NFL Network
said that the Giants are interested and
what do you do with Daniel Jones like do
you say hey hey we made you the starter
we got rid of the guy who was 38 we're
gonna go out and sign a guy who's 3
years old or take a seat for a year or
two or three but that would be a team
that could stick it to the Patriots
Giants would land Tom Bray
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports